wrong we are hey guys ryan right i'm
gerry how we hit 30,000 subscribers
today that's pretty [ __ ] ya jerk off
side that's what we need right now I
just like 50 you meet it for never
before I just 40 they're not 300,000
that'd be awesome that is a number we
will hopefully have one you will not do
any more shout outs until we get to
300,000 subscribers so get on a table
spread the word yeah share like comment
on your facebook oh all that [ __ ] oh no
she isn't annoying at basel yet that's
good but no we wanted to say thank you
if you're new and you're recently part
of the the real rejects community i like
to say that because i think it makes you
know people feel more involved I know
when one of these days we'll have to get
around like social networking site we
should like like a forum all of it I
mean we got every careful with that we
have a careful or on their forums can be
double-edged swore yeah you know else
can sex without a coma yeah yeah that's
very much double edge area yeah there's
all kinds of crazy things out there yeah
eat a cold no I don't think that's
possible oh that's not dangerous will
make some 30,000 subscribers thank you
guys and I thought it'd be interesting
if Jimmy obviously the other rejects are
not here well I mean you're you are the
finger head you're the heart and soul
you are the root this tree grows out I
like to consider myself the moneymaker
so like you're like dat ass money anchor
or 30,000 subscribers I make a [ __ ] ton
of money definitely not
working on it though yeah that's why we
need your guy's help to fill my bank
account annual financial support from
viewers like you yeah this is most
sincere video we've ever done no sorry
thank you it's kind of trippy than
30,000 people are there I'm sure not all
30,000 you watch these religiously but
yeah they do every video thirty thousand
thirty Seconds infuse well then those
are all your videos o mine usually cap
outta like 1500 oh yeah great yet great
stuff man well thank you keyboard was
trying to say like Jerry or my favorite
and then I like I go through their
profile whoo the [ __ ] favors Jerry over
me and I I just get mad so basically I
wanted to do a little reflection you
know when Jerry and I first started the
channel we need one of those like ripple
effect sound like we we had no idea what
we were really doing we just need we
wanted to talk about movies and it was a
[ __ ] to set up to five hours David
shayari 5 hours of me not helping and
when we tried to do the Avengers yeah we
tried for months on how to just get one
review out and then those reasons to see
have weird that was the main theme God
history so then straight to the point
came along GP then I just want to talk
about it so the blog came on we started
doing like shorts and stuff who just
really yeah it was like a hydrating hot
girls on the channel we started doing
straight to the point and then you got
your own place that it was like I got
all this free space now and all this
free time I live across town [ __ ] I'm
just got film some more videos yeah and
now you got your review show breeding
season spoiler review [ __ ] guys God
thanks I'm Shay and we're giving you
real rejects history right here London a
lot of change does it take place a lot
of morphs and shifts and things I got a
girlfriend which everyone is sick of me
talking about oh so I just keep
mentioning it for some reason just to
make this sicker yeah part of me is
getting defensive
was gonna mention it more than hey yeah
I should should be proud that is usually
go I've read some of these comments and
since the channels to become a lot more
diverse yeah see we're both we got to
talk about this [ __ ] on camera on the
air doesn't that light is on this is all
a studio so like if we're not supposed
to make any noise oh there's a crew of
75 people here right now yeah it takes a
lot to make one of these mm-hmm half of
them are black interesting choice he
chose that a lot of it yes I wanted to
be you know like really make half of the
black I just wanted you know to hire a
lot of diverse people Why should there
be only white people are more yeah it's
only white people and black people here
so um that's like a weird way of being
culturally income to saying it's like I
will only hire white people with black
people with nobody in between I've ever
reading comments about someone was upset
does he saying i think im gonna unsub to
your channel because you guys were just
you're reacting to games too much just
don't watch do so much the [ __ ] video
like it's that simple video game stuff
its own playlist yeah um it's when you
get a notification you get the title of
it yeah you can see if it's a gamer yes
this before like I'm sick of this the
Prophet up in my inbox yeah I mean we
there's still movie trailer rag and then
like people will request this shits
honestly really funny people will
request videos for us to watch and if
they don't get it in like two days they
start flipping the [ __ ] am I feel like
one day we ought to make some kind of
documentary which showcases like what it
actually takes to do so many of these
all time comes mostly explaining on a
shout our request that hey there's a lot
of requests so you got away your turn
same thing goes for all through all that
for all the videos it goes the same
there's a lot of requests so I'm the
same back on
there's a lot yeah thank you I just try
to make you happy one and you know a
five-minute video takes a lot longer
than you think to make yeah that's why
most of them are not even five minutes
eight minutes long yes well so you can
you when you get a little bigger you got
30,000 subs that's right at five min a
YouTube thing people love us too much to
stop after five minutes we plan on
shooting the super short look at a lot
of women yeah let's just make this a 40
video thank you video we're gonna go
down our subscriber list and thank all
30 dozen ever selling and not just a
quick name say just will give a full-on
shout out I'm tell a story about each
one of your child it's gonna be some
real [ __ ] up [ __ ] first remember when
I met WWE man anyway thank you guys you
have a good night yeah thank you see you
see you at 40,000 hopefully what I come
on muffin man to unsubscribe he's like
this dick who just keeps being dig to
get more girlfriends I don't know man
muffled man your an [ __ ] and you know
he's gonna do he's gonna stay subscribe
to keep talking [ __ ] to me that's a
cycle just one of those guys looks to
bust your chops Veronica's always saying
why don't you block him he's verbally
abusive readable I don't have to check
this out there's a lot of stuff that
goes i know this and I'm like its kind
it's it makes me laugh that I will
insult him on camera and he'll stay
subscribed just didn't sew me back maybe
that's what you need maybe he's your
Joker yeah he's just ever there to bust
your chuck in a lot of ways I am like
that because I got this really dark side
with also this really horny side and we
all know that man what I see the thing
is I'm waiting I'm waiting for like the
point in every show like every TV show
we're like they make a dress
shifting the characters so like I'm
waiting for the comments to come in
where Lloyd MIT was better before you at
group yeah it's better before everybody
what he was hitting on every woman that
walked into that room yeah I like the
same joke over no pretty good right
horny we get it's like the show really
went downhill when Ryan became happier
that's what I'm worried about losing
weight because I've been losing weight
and now I'm worried I people today is
funny or mean it was fat that's what you
should you just get a girlfriend get
skinny get rich just like get go Dean
cook you know yeah super bug and have
all of the sex yeah Thank good wow this
is supposed to be done like seven
minutes just don't cut it just this
until everything out all right Cheers
gotta take thank you